so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody my name is thomas
dobasiola whatever you want to call me
i'm here with marty o'neal what's up
folks what up this is the dopes usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between today guys we have
a very special guest i'm [ __ ] excited
about let's get right into it this is
ricky williams thank you for being here
ah thanks for having me thanks for being
here man i was trying to like
we were talking before the show and i'm
trying to pace myself i haven't seen you
quite so like i'm hyped i'm a football i
play football my whole life
my whole damn life yeah so this is this
is a real one for us for sure
i'm excited oh yeah yeah thank you for
being here man thanks for having me um
first question i always ask everybody i
always do my little research but i don't
want to do all my research and go i
already knew that yeah you know what i'm
saying so where did you grow up because
i know where you went to school where
you played but where did you grow up i
grew up in san diego california no [ __ ]
yep 619. did not know that yeah
so the whole idea my favorite place yeah
so damn
damn did you try to get on the chargers
at any point i wanted to so
you know if if i would have left my
junior year there's a good chance i
would have ended up oh instead of doing
senior year football exactly but i won
the heisman so it's worth it you know
but the truth is when i was growing up i
didn't want to be a professional
football player i wanted to be a
professional baseball player but i
wanted to play college college football
that was my my dream really but then i
got to college
and i did so well that it just kind of
became you know people everyone told me
and i believed it that i'd be dumb if i
didn't go to the nfl so
wow well that's a lucky problem you were
like two to three sport athletes exactly
exactly i wrestled i knew i wasn't
saying you wrestled like i realized i
loved it too i wrestled too yeah my
cousin just won nationals actually my
cousin jojo yeah first person adam
merced everywhere in nationals
yeah it's pretty cool yeah i loved it
yeah um when did you stop wrestling or
did you wrestle all the way through i
wrestled all the way through
i didn't start until my junior year so i
wrestled my junior and my senior year oh
you're just an athlete man if you just
picked it up in junior year i was
starting around like fifth grade you
know just to get it down i was an
athlete but just the way my my mind
works in like the like the one-on-one
combat and like gotta think quick and
kind of like sense what they're doing
and how do i counter it and then the
going for the kill it just was like the
the strategy of it and it's like real
and i'm quick and strong and so i had an
advantage and then i just had to learn
but it was awesome yeah once you get the
fundamentals down it's hard to
to stop a sprawl and someone [ __ ]
firemen carrying your out what are you
really gonna do
you know head and arm was my like i got
someone i had a nice
it's a wrap it's over
i told this story recently i loved
wrestling and uh i hadn't seen my friend
in fifth grade you know we go to
different middle schools but my friend
phillip he's a fat kid with me we're a
lineman yeah
i'm going up to wrestling i'm like
phillip he just [ __ ] hit puberty buff
as [ __ ] that's full chicken winged me
two rounds two periods
chicken wing me i was staring at my
grandma the whole time because i
couldn't move
worse experience in my [ __ ] life
did you uh ever get your ass i mean i
did i did my first my first match but i
will say that the person that beat me
steven neal ended up winning like uh
national championship in college into
playing for the patriots oh so yeah he
was he was a stud it was my it was like
like a ass whooping entree into
into uh into wrestling so yeah he went
my ass i took it but i learned and i
kept getting better i kept getting
better and i actually ended up winning a
tournament nice yeah and i pinned the
guy in like 12 seconds you got him in a
pipe range i got him in a pipe wrench my
favorite move and i type wrench why
haven't i heard what is that it's a it's
you know in the starting position if you
can get your hands like around his neck
and pull down and walk him forward you
get a pin like because his head goes oh
yeah yeah that's all my dad always said
they're trying to fall use your momentum
and throw them down yeah that's that's
my dad and the in the face i did it once
i felt terrible yeah hitting someone in
the [ __ ] you're fighting him at that
point yeah all right so you wrestled you
played baseball and that was your first
love that's my first house was baseball
yeah did you play as a kid yeah since i
was seven
oh [ __ ] little kid
do you have the tony gonzalez name like
which sport you gonna play exactly and i
was actually drafted by the phillies and
so out of high school i went out of high
school i went straight to virginia i
played minor league baseball and then i
went to texas
uh for the for the fall and i did that
all through college every summer i'd go
play minor league baseball all four
years so you're playing two seasons
flying somewhere
you weren't getting paid for this though
because i was i was but i wasn't on
scholarship because there's a there's a
i mean i could have if you're playing
professional in one sport you can't be a
on scholarship in any other any sport so
the baseball paid for my uh paid for my
education and they gave me money so i
was like i was chilling in college the
rich kid expected the dorms and it was
cool because you know growing up we
didn't have anything and and for me to
be able for my baseball ability even
before you know i went to college i was
able to to make enough money to pay for
my sister to go to college and to have a
comfortable college experience and so it
was awesome nice man that's amazing good
[ __ ] so you're in san diego grow i did
not know you're from california
i'm gonna say that right now i had no
idea so you're from in california and
you're going to texas to go to school
and then virginia yeah are you coming
back
so i i would come back yeah for
christmas come back for christmas and
then yeah because i was i was the
summers were all baseball and then the
rest of time was school so i'd have a
little bit of time to come back
a grown man at 18.
ham so did they have to like persuade
you to come play football it's got to be
a unique situation like this kid barely
even wants to play the sport you know
it's
i didn't want to play professional
sports but i always wanted to be a
college athlete i just when i you know i
watched that movie when i was a kid the
program and just watching notre dame
football growing up there was something
about college football that i was like i
want to be a part of that it was rudy
for me yeah yeah i think i could because
i was a
i just i talked about this last night to
my friend
i'm very good at sports even though i'm
a fat guy but you know i know you know
they're lining with the [ __ ]
quickness and i know you know that so
when i was growing up they're like yo
you're going to be on the line and go
but let me like try out for [ __ ]
quarterback and i
smoked all three kids and they go away
you and city league go you're a lineman
bro you're too [ __ ] heavy because i
had to i was that kid that run with the
bags before [ __ ] the game you know
what i mean that was me but i remember
thinking
just let me get that ball for the let me
run the ball one time in my life i gotta
go three yards but that was how did it
feel to push these [ __ ] all the
way back
i'll juice stuff right now there's
nothing like it there's nothing else
like laying a [ __ ] on his back
you got a legendary almost sacked though
right
so
there's this kid we did yeah we did we
you know you did tape obviously but did
you do a freshman here did you no
exactly why the [ __ ] were you doing tape
on a saturday i was pissed we did take
freshmen as a freshman we're good but
we're not that good now i'm just
refreshing yeah and there's this kid
that's tall here they keep talking about
i'm like all right who cares who cares i
never got a sack but i get through the
line every five seconds just too slow i
chase the [ __ ] and somebody else
gets it yeah but i remember i hit this
guy
he hit me and i mean when i hit him he
did the
hip toss drew my ass
ran and won
i'm watching the nfl
four years later
and it's [ __ ] calling kaepernick
he's right outside my town i didn't know
it was the same [ __ ] dude till the
nfl draft and that's my foot my only
good football story that suck we lost
yeah but that's that's mine and i know
you he's like yeah and i've tackled
people before but that was my like only
football thing i ever can remember that
was good besides blocking [ __ ]
though yeah but you know did you ever
play any other position than running
back when i first started playing
actually in high school i played a lot
of defense i played uh linebacker and a
little bit of safety i actually like
defense better
but often you know you get more it's a
touchdown exactly exactly stiff arm
[ __ ] exactly yeah i got it i
got it so
baseball how i because i didn't even
know that so how did you decide as you
said everybody else is persuading you
like well i honor the truth was i was
better at football oh you know i was
better at football baseball if i would
have you know played more i think i
could have i could have caught up but
but football is just better and so
the humiliation of working to get better
at baseball or being potentially the
best in the world at football
yeah yeah i guess it was hard it was it
was hard to say no so yeah i went to i
went to play football so you're growing
up you're playing all three sports i
always ask everybody this moment when
did you because there's always a moment
because i've done it where you come home
and you're like
by yourself for a second and you realize
i think this is what i'm supposed to do
did you have that moment young you know
it it was it wasn't like that it was
when i was a kid my mom said you're
going to college and i'm not paying for
it
that was a moment where i was like okay
i'm getting a scholarship you know like
i just knew
uh but the moment where it was a reality
was my uh my sophomore year we were
playing like kearney and they're one of
the best teams in the in the in the city
and i had like eight carries for 140
yards i just went off yeah and i kind of
that's when i knew okay i might have
something and then the next game i was
running the ball and i thought i was
just running people just kept bouncing
off of me and i was like i guess i got
something here so that's when i knew
that i had something special and that a
scholarship was going to be a reality
but when i was seven i kind of already
started like
you know manifesting it or putting it
into into reality because my mom my mom
told me you're doing it so i was like
got it oh she told you
yes
yeah you said savagely seven going to
college and i'm not gonna pay for it
what a good motivation it worked for
real get your [ __ ] together yeah
seven-year-old my mom my mom and your
mom sound the same man yeah that's just
kind of like that because you're putting
the kid off on a path with a mission
yeah if you read your shares you know
and i wish i had that young you know i
mean you're here you hit 19 you see
other younger fools you're like ill try
this i see where you're going i just
wish i had that when i was younger but i
mean i'm not mad about it yeah but i'm
sure
do you have you said you had a sister
right do you have anybody older no i
didn't have i didn't i wish i would have
had that too
you know but it would have had to be
someone that i respected because if it
was just some dude i'd have been like
but i wish i would have someone i'd
looked up to and respected that that had
my best interest and more and like
and that's why i think it's so important
for me to be that for other people
because you know like
like you know like you said the tagline
like i've been through [ __ ] right and so
i think what i can hand down to people
are just insights so that they can just
move through the [ __ ] that we all have
to go through a little bit faster
exactly the part that's what we preach
every episode yeah yep his struggles on
the east coast this this mine over here
somebody's relating somehow and better
themselves by going let me expedite this
process and not [ __ ] up like you did yes
and let me just listen to the episode
for one day exactly yeah yeah that's
good man and before we started you said
you started a program yeah but i'm gonna
jump ahead a little bit you started a
program and it's for cannabis
connoisseurs yes so how did you i mean
you're sitting there smoking weed and go
you know what i could tease a
[ __ ] or something you know you
know it's i'm not i'm not teaching the
class i'm taking the class so
so i received i received the email about
a year and a half ago
and it's called a gone ga program and i
was like hahaha and i kind of looked at
it and i was like you know they're
actually like i love school i love
learning love love it and so i was like
i could actually like learn more about
this wonderful plant
and there's a program to do it and i
like got on the website and i saw that
the class was full next next semester i
did the same thing the class was full so
we started heisman and another email
came through and i asked our head of
marketing i say reach out to them and
just see you know if they're interested
and they let us know that uh good
morning america is coming to to film
them and they you know want to pump up
the
their company so they said hey why don't
you come take the class now yeah exactly
and they took care of it so i was like
hell yeah
uh
i just have such good luck with like
school all these scholarships you know
i've taken so many educational programs
and found a way either the nfl paying
for it or or baseball paying for it or
just because i'm a good guy and i love
to learn people looking at so it's just
been like i have good karma around
education so i started the program
and not knowing exactly what to expect
just knowing i was going to learn some
[ __ ]
and the the very first like class is
about the history of cannabis right and
and brilliant and so speaking of yeah
sorry i got lost man here here
smoking that up thank you
speaking of sorry you start you're
learning yeah so history the history of
cannabis and they went straight they
went straight to the history of
civilization history of humanity to show
this plan is 28 million years old and we
have a long
long history with this plant that's been
obscured for us over the past 100 years
or so and so really jumping back into
the history of cannabis i got i got
really emotional because when i left the
nfl and i'm sure we'll talk about this
more when i left the nfl back in 2004
part of part of what i did was i went on
a journey to because there wasn't a lot
of information about cannabis at the
time and i was curious if i just gave up
everything i've worked my whole life for
for this plant i need to understand more
about this plan and so i went on a
journey and i found myself
pretty much going to a lot of the same
places that these historians went to
find to find their information like i
ended up in the himalayas in india oh
[ __ ] driving up the himalayas and
looking out the window and just seeing
like like cannabis growing like
naturally in nature and i and having
that experience it
it like changed something for me you
know to see it in its natural habitat
it was like this isn't a this all this
stuff we've been told like it's kind of
[ __ ] when you see this is a plant
this is a plant and that people have
been using for thousands of years for
spiritual purposes
you know and and i'm so glad that the
program starts there because that's
where cannabis started and and i and i
feel like so much alignment because i
felt like since i got in trouble with
the nfl like my journey has been really
to bring this message
right to whoever's willing to listen
and
in my story being a heisman trophy
winner being a high achiever in
utilizing cannabis to help me do that
i feel that's an empowering story and it
it it's redemption for all of us
all of us
people that went to jail
people families all [ __ ] up over it
yeah it's redemption for all of us
because to me
it's so funny and this is just my
personal opinion so many people in the
world like get worried about like little
insignificant [ __ ]
so so much and and i think it's because
we've lost perspective and i was one of
those people too
and i started smoking and what it gave
me was perspective
was perspective and i allowed me to see
things differently and to make choices
that allow my life to be more meaningful
and to me like that's the great that's
the greatest gift you can give to
someone is the opportunity this is i
think what you guys are doing helping
people find more meaning in their life
yes meaning of the things that happen in
the past and then thinking future in the
future okay like because here's what
i've noticed is when i look back at all
the things that have happened to me in
the past it's obvious to me that they've
been preparing me for what's coming now
right and if we understand that then we
can start to realize all the crazy [ __ ]
that happened in the past is like
building is building us preparing us and
it allows us to look in the future and
to get a sense of like where where am i
headed so we can be part of that process
you know like when i when i got to
college
uh we were 1995. we were in the the
study the computer lab and our head of
study hall said we gotta you guys gotta
create email addresses all right and i
raised my hand and i said what's email
first day of calling yes and she broke
she broke it down for us and i was like
what am i gonna choose and i was like ah
heisman right as a goal so i my email
address was with heisman at u.texas.edu
and four years later i happened to win
the heisman but that's what i was saying
i had an image of like where am i headed
and i started to like build towards that
image and so much of it was when i had a
bad game you know i'd go home and i'd
smoke a little bit and i let go of the
like
the bad like the feeling of having a bad
game and i'd start to like engage and
okay who do we got next week and can i
imagine myself like killing it and it
would work every time manifestation yes
exactly but and people talk about
manifestation and they talk about
spirituality but they don't talk about
it i think with cannabis enough because
to me what happens when people try to do
visualization or materialization they're
trying to create something positive but
they have all these negative thoughts
and so the positive thoughts they go out
there but the negative thoughts like eat
them up
right there's doubt but when you smoke
and you like let go of the [ __ ] and
you have more of this expansive mindset
that's the time to visualize because you
you're not bogged down by all your
doubts and all your fears you haven't
you have you're open to more possibility
it's a different vibration it's a
different vibration yeah it's like with
mushrooms like you better be chilling
because those vibrations and frequencies
are gonna [ __ ] your trip up if you're
worrying about this and worrying about
that i remember when i started first
getting really deep into weed really
doing that people thinking i was [ __ ]
crazy talking about it yeah like no you
don't understand i'm in my i'm in the
[ __ ] bentley in cali you know
and it's just different like you really
feel exhilarated by it you're really
there it's really mine yes i really have
something i'm working towards
the feeling of having it i know what it
feels like that's what i'm working
towards yes that and the problem is
though is that you got to take that back
into when you get up the next day and
really start to like
use that inspiration to take take action
exactly no and i think that's like
but because of the stigma and the taboo
and people are told that it makes you
lazy then they like act like it's true
but the reality is it makes you lazy so
that you can let go of the [ __ ] and
receive a vision so then you know what
to do if you're a beast you're going to
be a beast no matter what that's me and
my girlfriend having this back and forth
for the past [ __ ] 50 years i've been
saying from the start like if you're
going to be a lazy [ __ ] that's
just your path yes 100 i'm going to have
a psychotic work ethic this is just
gonna help me get in my zone yes
that's what i'm yeah yeah i smoke weed
while i do orders and edit like the [ __ ]
yeah dude it's
it's the work it is always the work
ethic and the mindset of a person
because um
i know a lot of people that smoke weed
all day every day that are constantly
working and building businesses
you know but but this what i'm saying is
to me my people might think this is
crazy i think that's more of of
how it should be
yeah how it should be i mean not forever
but the way i think of because i'm
always thinking about this is like what
what is this what is going on and one of
the things is it's a it's a feminine
plant we all know that and it puts us in
touch with our feminine side meaning our
feelings right and when people smoke and
they say they get paranoid it's because
they always are stuffing their feelings
you should be best yes it's funny
out here yes yeah but but it's like when
do we smoke they're just aware of the
stuff that's already in there and the
paranoia to me is just it trying to like
come to your awareness so that you can
do something about it it might overwhelm
people and that's when they freak out
well because they because they don't
have the confidence to think that they
can handle it mm-hmm you know i don't
know if anybody's broken that down
better yeah that's like he's
exactly like i can't marty preaches this
[ __ ] so much that's where religion
really comes in for me here we go people
want answers to that they want a nice
safe
answer to that fear yeah and it's like
you just gotta you just gotta accept the
[ __ ]
and if you accept it the answers come
the fear comes because you don't have
faith that's like a fear is the
punishment for not having faith and it's
the ability to move towards faith right
because if you're afraid and you do it
anyway what happens is oh you realize i
don't need to be afraid and you develop
more faith yeah it's true yeah first
time jeb would have a high dive yeah it
only took that one [ __ ] time as a kid
and then you're doing flips by the end
of the day
it's the same thing with life a lot of
people are afraid of change because they
don't know if they can do it yeah that's
the biggest
style you can look back at your path
from seven years old and see you like
implemented that [ __ ] like i'm gonna do
a bunch of different [ __ ] and see where
i end up i was lucky i mean like people
give religion a hard time and i think
it's been it's abused people like
horribly but but the one thing that it
taught me was faith faith just the the
basic principle of faith that at least
believe and then check the result
believe and then check the results and
football teaches you that too in
football if you're too afraid to make a
mistake you're not gonna you know right
you see that like on defense right i'm
blitzing outside but i see that the
lineman is overset and i just cut inside
even though i'm not supposed to but i
react and i g and i and i it works but
if i was like oh i got to follow the
rules coach said uh you know
i don't make the play and so you got to
learn to take risks to to know like to
know yourself
and that's how you develop faith i think
it's take you take risk and then you got
to see
it worked out okay okay i can have faith
oh it didn't work out all right maybe i
need to try something else yes and faith
i think is a lot of having faith in
yourself as a person not even like faith
in a higher power and high this it's
you can your reality depends on you but
but i think that's the starting point
but ultimately it has to to me it has to
go to a faith in something greater
because
because we can believe in ourselves and
then we other people we start to get
afraid of that they're they're messed up
right they're messed up but if we
believe in a higher power then we can
see how we're connected to everyone oh
yeah i think everything yes also yes
because i know trees can talk to each
other
they're on a different frequency than us
yes that's it mushrooms communicate with
each other you know what i mean oh this
one's dying send [ __ ] help through
the roots yeah everything is connected i
always compare how many times i'm going
to talk about fern gully everything's
[ __ ] connected to that damn movie
yeah um it truly is everything is
how do you say it when when twins aren't
together and they feel something it's
because their biology is exactly the
same yeah you if you have that intuition
i think people that
it's not enlightened it's their
brains opened a little more yeah you
know you know that's the definition of
so in enlightened is like a is a
spectrum
right it's not no one is ever fully
enlightened because the infinite is the
universe is infinite but there's always
greater levels of enlightenment and
and i think that's why you know i had a
call today with our with our marketing
team and you know we're talking about
our messaging and really elevating our
messaging
and the word i was using was spiritual
because i didn't have another word and
one of our our team members suggested
the word enlightenment and this is this
idea of there's there's some kind of
darkness something where we're not quite
sure it's cloud we don't have clarity
right and then we sit back and we're
talking to a friend smoking man whatever
and then the the literally the light
comes on yeah it's almost more like
elevator doors coming back then you know
like being kind of more aware of like
like you're saying your overall
perception of
life coming at you and how you think
about it so the first time i heard
someone speak positively about cannabis
is i was i was studying uh
alternative medicine
and herbs and my teacher was talking and
he said it was funny he said whenever i
have a problem and and i can't seem to
solve it any other way he said then i'll
smoke a little bit to get a different
perspective and that was the first time
i ever heard anyone i looked up to or
respected like say that and i felt like
when he said it i've two things one i
was like ah i have language now to
understand what's going on and two
that's what's been going on the whole
time and so so much of what i'm trying
to do with this brand is get that
message out there because that people
just need to hear it to have the
language to understand what's going on
because the old language that we had is
it's bad for us
all of this like stuff that's not true
and so it's in our heads and we have to
like wrestle with that in order to like
get here but now i'm saying that now
that we're here let's take it to the
next level and let's like change the
conversation so that more people having
these kinds of conversations opening
their mind becomes what what it's about
and i and i feel like that's something
that at least for me that i feel like we
can all get behind of course yeah and i
think all of our fans are like-minded
people i mean if you we're offensive and
we talk about dumb [ __ ] and but we do
talk about real things in life and how
to get it done this is one thing that
could improve everything the quality of
every city in the country like
oh yeah immediately yeah it's coming
soon it'll be it'll be here soon and i
think it's going to be
a whole different life
it is you know it is it is and the
beauty is that if that we're in a
position right now that we can be a big
part of creating that
of creating it and i think this is like
the world today where
you know you can have a room like this
and set up some cameras and have these
kinds of conversations and a lot of
people are right the things that are
coming out of our mouths are going to go
into a lot of people's heads and like
spur other ideas yes and they're going
to share and it's going to spark other
ideas
positivity radiates yes you know i mean
if you can keep it it's like a torch and
if you can keep it going i mean it's
like it's just keeps going for [ __ ]
ever and that's how uh
i like to live our lives marty too
that's why i think me and marty
connected so well and the people we have
on
i like this it seems like kind of like a
mutual
theme of like a lot of people a lot a
lot of our guests not everyone but
a lot of it has articulated it that's
what i'm trying to do maybe that's
trying to articulate nobody's
articulating yes that's what i'm trying
to say i'm probably older than a lot of
the no no really no no we've had a lot
of
uh yeah i know we have uh she got some
old cats in here yeah
chillin yeah we're at tommy chong he's
like 85 probably wow yeah we're chilling
man we don't have a lot of younger
guests if anything that's true
35 i'm 32.
that's so cool yeah that's cool we're uh
we're in the so that means yes i grew up
with thurman thomas and jim kelly in
them yeah all the super bowl
you know all about it right he's from
buffalo so when i when i'm mad and i
play with buffalo nice because i got a
good quarterback a good defensive
defensive secondary yeah and they got
two good running backs
yeah it's like a it's like a yo peyton
manning styles back but you can run yeah
yeah i love it so we just got up on
miller yeah
yep that's a big set oh you signed diggs
yeah buffalo's my team again let's go
i'm here for a packer fan so right now
we're not looking great
we just got rid of that we just got rid
of our number one receiver but you got
the best quarterback in the game i know
but he's pissed off right now oh no he's
upset
at his own team i feel
yo what's up guys just taking a break in
the episode to talk about one of our
long time sponsors this is manscaped
before i get into anything guys you
already know
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off of anything and everything
on the site plus free shipping on all of
it so that's 20 off your whole order
plus free shipping using code yola at
checkout so if you didn't know guys
april is tessicular cancer awareness
month and if you're like me a guy you
probably have balls and getting cancer
in your balls must suck so that's why
manscape is doing testicular cancer
awareness month they just want to bring
more attention to this because this is a
serious thing that people don't really
talk about so in april the performance
package 4.0 for manscape is something
that you should get for your husband
your friend or maybe yourself so the 4.0
lawnmower guys you have already seen it
in our commercials you see it in all of
our ad reads it's something i have at my
house and i have more in the warehouse
you guys already know it's wireless
charging led light on it it's like
shaving your dick in the future so once
again guys go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off of anything and everything
plus free shipping on your entire order
once again thank you guys so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode
one thing before i
i really wanted to ask when we talked to
your booking agent
he he or she i don't remember he hit the
email
game has hit his back and says ricky
williams
he's really into astrology and he needs
your birthday
place of birth am i oh what
i think he's like oh it's for astrology
oh okay dale's getting a background
check oh [ __ ]
so how did you get into this it's a
background check um
you know what i was like yeah it's a
criminal one
i was looking for answers i was looking
for answers always looking for answers
always looking for answers i met this
woman
she walked up to me she said where's
your marsh
i said what she said where's your mars
i said i don't know what you're talking
about lady and she said do you know
where you should you know what time you
were born i said yes she said tell me
and i told her my information and she
put it on her computer and she started
talking to me about my mars and i was
like i don't even know i had a mars and
then i asked her like what is this and
she started to explain it to me
and i just got really curious and so i
started doing my own research and i was
like damn i just started seeing
possibilities like this is really
amazing and it helped me really learn
about myself learn about life and i just
was so passionate about it i kept
studying it
and almost 20 years later now you know
that's what i do for a living i talk to
people about about themselves
it's awesome so as someone that has no
idea other than when i was in the
newspaper they would have your sign and
what your
intentions are of the damage to read it
every morning yeah i know nothing past
that yeah so when someone says a virgo
you should probably be like is this
accurate
um yes and no yes and no so when i look
at a chart
i'm looking at
34 pieces of information
34 different pieces of information and i
interpret that
but when you look at a horoscope it's
looking at two pieces of information so
it's
it's it's kind of accurate but it's only
like a very small slice i'm sorry i'm in
astrology in general when they're
talking about the signs 100 percent
but when you say accurate it it depends
uh
you have to understand what astrology is
it's
astrology cannot predict or describe a
person it can describe energies so
astrology is a language of energy so
when i like when when that woman said
where's your mars the reason she was
asking me that question is because
someone told her i was a football player
okay and and the the energy that mars
relates to is aggressive energy and so
she knew that if someone was a
professional football player they must
have a lot of strong aggressive energy
and so she wanted to see what that
looked like in a chart
and so she looked at my chart and in my
chart the planet mars in my chart is
aggressive and so she was like oh yeah
and that's what that's when i was like
this random woman comes up to me from
hearing a piece of information and she
looks at the chart and it's validated
that's why i was that caught my
attention and then i started digging
more and i kept seeing like more and
more
awarenesses and insights that were
coming through this perspective and and
again to me astrology is an energy of of
language and
i mean a language of energy and when i
say language it's like we feel something
but if we don't have the words to put to
what we feel then it's hard for us to
describe and explain to someone else
what we feel
but if we
if we understand ah
and this is what it's studying astrology
has helped me do i understand i wake up
in the morning
and i'm feeling like pissed off or like
irritated okay i can look at the chart
and i i know that's mars 100 that's mars
and so i can look at the chart and say
what's mars doing and i can understand
and get some insight about why i'm
feeling pissed off or what to do about
it
really yes or
so like when our moods change or we're
noticing inner things okay astrology can
tell you what's going on
it can help you understand like what's
up
really yes okay you know like how
sometimes like for me sometimes there's
a certain kind of sneeze
and when i sneeze i know a cold is
coming oh it's 100 right it's it's back
in the back of my nose yeah i am going
i'm sick yes yes yeah i could taste it a
little yes it's kind of like that like
recognize it's right you recognize it
and you're like okay i know it's coming
so you can prepare for it in the same
way with the astrological energies like
and it's also people right so
like there's mars people right and these
are people that are just aggressive
overly aggressive people they always
need to know it's mean like it means
aggression like that's what it means
mars means aggression and so mars to the
ancient romans was the god of war
exactly exactly and but in a positive
sense because aggression can manifest in
a lot of different ways okay the purpose
of it is passion to overcome obstacles
right competition right you know my
teacher says two dogs and one bone so
it's like an innate like thing that we
needed to survive right to overcome
obstacles right
so we can use it to overcome obstacles
or if we can if we get become afraid
then it turns into like anger and then
we like take it out on other people okay
right so you see someone who's being
overly like aggressive you know that's a
mars problem you see someone who's
overly like passive and they're not
standing up for themselves that's a mars
problem
wow so you could you could really just
like so when she came what's your mars
you can now go up to a person and ask
them that exactly
exactly and they'll say what are you
talking about and then we'll sit down
especially if they're especially if i
see them being overly aggressive i know
that i can sit down to that person and
look at their chart and we can have a
meaningful conversation about what's
going on for them right now
because i can
get back to balance basically exactly
because all of the energies they're
trying to express and mars is tricky
because most of us are taught like when
we're a kid and someone takes our toy
and we smack them we're taught don't do
that hands or hands are not for hitting
so we're a lot of unless we find sports
or some other kind of outlet a lot of us
don't know how to handle our aggression
right so you see some people are
comfortable with competition they love
it some people shy away from it a lot of
that is our training but we all have
that we all have a mars okay we all have
passion some people have more some
people have less
and
and mars can help you understand that
here's a good example in relationship
astrology one of the first things to
look for is mars
because the relationship is you have two
people trying to do something together
and they need to be equals on some level
okay and so if one person has a very
strong margin another person doesn't the
person with the strong mars is always
going to be the bully of the
relationship and the one with the weak
margin is always going to be the victim
and so on a relationship it's important
for two people to have strong mars's so
that they can stand up to each other or
for two people not to have strong mars
and so they both agree to get along and
the other thing that mars is aggressive
is an erection
okay and like being turned on that's a
mars event okay it's and you can feel
that like when we get pissed off right
the energy comes up and we have to like
do something to move it to express it
and it's the same thing we get turned on
right we got to do something to move it
to express it and so like mars has a lot
to do with sexuality in the sense of
being active activated and turned on so
in in our history i mean there's ways to
get around it now but in the history of
like procreation you got to be turned on
to procreate
you know this is mars and so people that
have a strong mars have a strong sex
drive
and that's right so you have two people
in a relationship and you want it to
work you got to make sure that the sex
drives are are compatible and you look
at mars for that
you know i've never heard anything i've
never heard a breakdown like nothing
it makes a lot of sense
i think it's
unreal that you can
pretty much talk to somebody about
what's going on in their lives based on
the energies that they're
i guess
get letting out and you can
i'm sorry i'm i'm trying to wrap my head
around probably like you did when you
first heard that what the [ __ ] trying to
explain something you're not yet
understand yes i'm trying to ask a
question you gotta tell me i can tell
you you're picking up how it works yeah
it's just unreal to me that you you that
somebody could do that you said in 34
pieces and i've only ever heard two yeah
exactly
okay so how about this like with
crystals and energies and because i know
my girlfriend's very in tune with
herself and she's always like okay all
right
this is going to happen soon we i feel
it blah blah this this planet and like
oh damn rosie yeah you're on it yeah so
with rocks and stuff my my friend og he
believes and he charges all his stuff he
does he's super into
in tune with his
brain i guess you would say so he gives
me certain ones like yo if we need to
put this in your house i need you to
have this rock in your house put this by
your bed keep pushing your car when you
travel i was like he's like just stay
safe i'm like
all right og's super into that yeah so i
have you know certain rocks rosie put
some ones in our bed
it's always kind of odd to me that that
certain rocks how does that okay there's
two ways
the one way is so
astrology as a language of energy
so what the way we would we would like
look at different stones different
crystals and we would say that they each
have like a main astrological vibration
so we would say this is a mars stone
like bloodstone okay in in rome ancient
roman soldiers would carry blunts
bloodstones to war because of the energy
so each everything can be classified by
one of the 34
symbols in astrology everything can
because that's why it's a language and
they can say
it's a language exactly exactly and so
so that's one that's one part of
crystals is that if you have a mars
crystal and you have the crystal with
you you have more mar you're adding to
your mars energy
so someone who has like a has too much
aggression and you give them a marsh
stone they're going to have even more
aggression someone who's having
difficult a difficult time standing up
for themselves you give them a marsh
stone they're going to have a little bit
more courage okay that's just the nature
of this the energy of the vibrations we
are energy exactly and so but the other
thing is the nature of crystals is
they're like energy batteries
meaning if you hold a crystal and you
think a certain thought about any
thought and you hold the crystal and you
think that certain thought the energy of
that thought is held by the crystal so
that's when people say amulets or
talisman you can take a crystal and you
can like hold it and you can think of
like prayers or good thoughts about a
person and you can give them the crystal
and that crystal will will for a certain
amount of time depending on how much you
put into the battery will radiate that
thought to the person how long did this
take for you to wrap your head around
that it's because this
most people are like yo what movie is
this
but i know that it's you know this is
part of our body this is why it's here
and it works with us for a [ __ ]
reason yes that's why certain plants are
like that's why it's for your body
exactly it's that's why we're here this
is our level of earth and i mean
everything's for us like a sustainable
game i get that
so when it comes to like
certain rocks when my girlfriend or it's
happened to me too i thought she was
tripping we went around this huge
[ __ ] i guess it's called amethyst
like the purple ones
huge like the size of my body and i got
light-headed as hell when i got around
it
i think i was just the energy yes i got
i legitimately i went what the [ __ ] like
i thought maybe did i just get too high
earlier yeah but i she said what the
[ __ ] are we
okay so it's both of us and that's the
first time this is like six seven years
ago it's the first time i ever thought
that [ __ ] might be real i genuinely felt
it in my body get whoa
dizzy yeah so why is that because so a
big crystal like they're they're
literally like
like batteries batteries and so when you
when you like walk by it it's like
giving you it's it's radiating something
and that's what you're that's what
you're feeling so somebody has that
crystal with bad intentions they could
radiate bad into 100 100
100
yes 100
this is a trick crystals are powerful
like that's what they do they they hold
it like even if you put a crystal out in
the sun and you pick it up what do you
notice it's hot of course it's hot oh i
got you guys see it's whole it's like
it's holding the energy right and it's
the same way it like radiation from the
sun is energy but our thoughts are
energy 100 our thoughts are energy so
how do these i'm gonna be i'm 100 out
there i've seen it happen where rosie
put her rocks out
on the windowsill in the morning they
are completely on the other side of the
[ __ ] window yeah every single time i
think do we have an earthquake
but it's every [ __ ] time oh we wake
up and her [ __ ] is slid over like half a
foot
what the [ __ ] they're really moving by
themselves overnight
that [ __ ] made me go okay i believe this
there's stuff there's i'm telling you
there's so there's a quote i think it
was uh saint augustine he said there's
no such thing as miracles there's just
things we don't yet understand
it's a good way to put that yeah and
that's why like think about cannabis it
opens your mind and it gives you
permission to go seek that understanding
because i think the the biggest
limitation people put on their mind is
they don't give themselves permission to
go even ask the question
right even because they're afraid afraid
of the answer
for me like there's no question that i'm
afraid of the answer because i'm always
searching for truth
that's faith in yourself yeah yeah
that's that's where i believe there's a
higher power so whatever truth i find i
know that it's going to be good for me
you sound like you dabble in other plant
medicines
yeah i do but cannabis is by far my
my favorite
because i think of the a lot of the
other plant medicines
they're i think they're more ceremonial
and more for like uh cleansing kind of
like uh kind of like a laxative yeah or
a flashlight your brain exactly exactly
so we say i think everybody every adult
should take mushrooms at least
twice a year yeah because it's like like
you said it's like an oil change yeah
it's unplugging everything
for everyone out there that's never done
mushrooms for me
i wake up with an entire
different respect and then the earth
starts giving me distractions and then
three days later it's back almost to
normal whatever yes because it's a
cleanse but the to me like the the tool
for everyday creativity and putting the
vision into action to me that's cannabis
right and i think just when you
understand the different plant medicines
you get a sense of you know what they're
good for yeah and yeah and how they fit
how they fit in your life that's the
beautiful thing about astrology because
this language it can help us understand
okay this is who i am
i understand my energies and so now i
understand what energies i i need more
of which i need to break from which i
need to crank up which i need to work on
you know that we have this ability to be
fluid with our environment
did you have this understanding why you
were playing football i start i was
starting to develop it the first part of
my career i didn't have it i retired in
2004 and i started traveling around the
world i went to india and i just spent
that whole year studying all this stuff
and creating a foundation and then when
i came back to play football for another
six years i was building i was building
and building on this this knowledge and
then when i retired in 2011 i started
traveling again and just like studying
and learning as much as i could so
you've been on the on the go since yeah
i have i feel like i'm a seeker of truth
and i've had the resources and the time
and the intelligence to be able to find
some really cool [ __ ] and the abilities
just literally paid your way to go do
whatever else you wanted to do exactly i
love this right so i i have a question
so on before i have the question thank
you for explaining that to me yeah that
really
i didn't know i love learning new [ __ ]
that i actually can take into
consideration because
i've
i believe in that [ __ ] because i know
it'll change it's you're a virgo yeah
it'll it'll change your it'll change
your life if you just start dabbling
with astrology because so virgo is a
sign of discrimination right analysis
okay all right here's what i here's my
virgo of pitch my virgo story i say you
know virgo is the virgin but it's not
really about sex it's about purity
and so like virgos usually have like an
ideal of what's right like what they're
aiming for but it's also on earth side
so it's very like humble and aware of
what it is right now so i say virgos are
always aware of the gap between where i
should be and where i am damn always
you know the hint is you got to balance
ceaseless effort because the awareness
of what can get better is not ever going
away
ceaseless effort with self-love meaning
you have to approach everything like a
craft like a crafts person honing the
craft honing the craft honing the craft
honing the craft honing the crest love
this i always say that like you got to
be the positive coach and the worker at
the same time yep because people it's
really easy to let that [ __ ] coach go
wow yeah and he's turning he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's that's you gotta because
dark virgo is is you get so nit-picky of
yourself it overflows and you start
nitpicking everyone else
that's dark
yeah i guess i call that my
perfectionist shitty brain yeah yeah
it's got to be perfect why did you [ __ ]
why are you [ __ ] up yeah yeah well
the reminder for virgo is it's about
it's the process of moving towards ah
that's what you gotta love yeah process
of moving through most functions it took
10 years
the process
that's the best part i would never trade
it and go back yeah yeah it took for
[ __ ] years of being broke and
struggling like is it going to work is
it going to work [ __ ] it might not work
keep trying because i love it yeah yeah
exactly wow so that [ __ ] was pretty dead
huh yeah yeah exactly first time in my
life where i'm like
because it's something actually really
materialized or i'm like this is what i
was working towards yes it's like that
was all the process yes this was what it
was the whole time but it doesn't stop
now it's looking into the future and
saying like what like what's the next
level of perfection that i'm working
towards 100 yeah everything it's not you
can stop you can't you can't ever stop
anything you can't because there's
always something that's like oh no i
could be better i put no time into that
yeah do you know mike dolce the trainer
i don't he's a
nutritionist for the ufc
and uh he was one of my clients and
something he said always stick with me
he's like you just you're flying up
these rungs of this ladder you're going
up to the ladder you can't wait to get
to the top you get to the top you look
up and there's just another [ __ ]
ladder yes
that's it that's how it goes yeah
i love it yeah i love that we've said
this before i would rather be
i would rather be never rich as [ __ ]
enough to never do anything again i
would rather be always working going
i'll get there i'll get there and
sometimes like that's a rat race
like no it's not it's
it's a video game to me yes yeah it's
always like what more can i do yeah yeah
it always makes me think of like when
i'm younger like yo what the [ __ ] yeah
can you believe it this was one of those
days for you yeah oh yeah for sure for
sure like you said growing up playing
football reggie white was my favorite
player that's my [ __ ] he was a
defensive tackle like or defensive end
no tackle sorry
and then uh gilbert brown was the nose
guard for the packers and i remember the
[ __ ] digging [ __ ] and that was me i
was a little [ __ ] like that's [ __ ]
me
you know but you know
you you're offensive line you're a fat
kid you end up in the offensive line
essentially um
but yeah that was me uh that's that's
how i feel and marty too like what's the
next thing we can do yeah yeah what else
can we perform i'll build a new set no
it can get better here yeah that's the
thing so if you learn like start
learning the language of astrology it
just allows you to be even more like
precisely i love this right on when
we're after this please give me like
something i can look at i got you yeah i
like this this is a
this is right up my alley man my whole
life right now is about trying to get
[ __ ] better yeah yeah because we've said
it we've built it now it's like no let's
[ __ ] foundation's there let's go
i'm trying right now marty too we just
[ __ ] built his house he's just moved
in last week he's done
yeah
let's go foundation
[ __ ] yeah we're trying to build right
now bad energy i know you can feel it
yeah
so my question was
when you're in college and you're
obviously smoking weed
are you getting in trouble because they
don't drug test in college for a week
they do they do actually they have
the so the ncaa test
they test and if you fail if you fail
the ncaa test your they suspend you for
a whole year
it's i mean they're changing it but that
was so cool i had two i had two
teammates both had nfl potential
they they they got popped and they
missed their whole scene both of them
missed their whole senior year it's
it just hurts me even to think about it
um that's changing but worse i coached
for a year in college and the
universities will test the kids and if
the universities you pop once a lot of
them will kick you out of school
so even if the ncaa changes their policy
the universities have to change their
policy also if the real marijuana
policies like no matter what the
government says it goes by county yeah
exactly so but things are changing it's
gonna we're gonna laugh at this and it's
gonna be it's gonna be silly and the
truth is i i smoked a little bit a
little bit in college because the the
upperclassmen were doing it
and then my senior year i smoked i
started my junior year and senior year i
started smoking a little bit more
um but my senior year is really when i
had like that meaningful moment where i
was like
i get it it's part of me yeah
that where
i saw that it had
true
value and meaning in my life
you know and and and it's it's very
freeing to be able to say that right
here like that but back then there was
no language to say that like i couldn't
say that and think i was sane it wasn't
like because things have changed so much
but that's exactly what it was i had i
had a couple of really bad games i'll
set up the story because i think it's
really interesting so i'll tell them
please
please tell the long version yeah so so
after my junior year in college my
junior year in at texas i led the i led
college in touchdowns and rushing yards
and i was thinking about going to the
nfl
they said i would have been a top five
pick and so i was thinking about going
to the nfl
and it was i had like a week to announce
to declare
and i was i was at uh in our sports
media guys office and i was flipping
through a sports almanac and i opened to
the page of the all-time leading rusher
in
in college football history it was tony
dorsett at the time and i looked at his
numbers and i looked at mine because i
was like seventh or something and i
looked at mine and i was like
if i had the same kind of year i had
this past year i could be the all-time
leading rusher in college football
history like just that it was like in
reach it was intriguing and then i
turned a couple of pages and i saw the
record for all-time touchdowns and i did
the math and i was like if i have the
same year i had this past year
i could have the most touchdowns in
college football history i was like damn
that's intriguing
a couple more pages that's all-purpose
yards same thing i was like i could have
i could be like one of the best college
football players ever if i can repeat
what i did this past year okay that was
like what i was thinking and the
opportunity just the opportunity to go
for that was too much to to pass up and
so i came back from my senior year okay
and so
coming back from my senior year within
the first two weeks of the season we get
our ass whooped by ucla and i find out
that my girlfriend is sleeping with the
or is hooking up with the the
quarterback geez you're jesus shuttle's
work yes oh so yes exactly i'm telling
you so so i like i'm having this at the
same time and like and i and my like i
was like i'm out of the race for the
heisman i'm like i'm off track to break
these records and now my girl is like
gone and the guy that she's with is
giving me the hand of me the football i
was like why did i come back for this
[ __ ] like i was you know i was in that
dark dark place and you probably passed
up a lot of money out of me oh yeah all
of i just a lot of i was just in this
[ __ ] and i was like why why did i pass
it up i was going there my mind was
going to that dark place and my and my
roommate and my roommate was like dude
you need to chill and he brought out his
little bong he was a smoker
and he had me hit it a couple times and
i didn't know what to expect but i went
up in my room i laid on the bed like my
mind was cleared about all the [ __ ]
and again i i put it behind me and i
started thinking about like okay like
what can i i'm here how can i make the
best of this situation okay
all right
next two weeks back to back three
300-yard rushing games
back-to-back
he's playing madden with himself
that doesn't even sound real i got to be
honest it i mean mr peyton didn't even
put up numbers like that yeah i think if
there's a record back-to-back i think
it's it's a record back-to-back 300-yard
games [ __ ] i think i did 315 and 350.
and and i was obviously back in the
heisman race my girl was still with the
guy they're married now but but i was
back i was back i was i was back in the
heisman race and everything is it's a
happy story and and that was the that
was the moment i said that was a moment
where i realized damn like the [ __ ]
opened the door yeah wow yeah because no
matter what i was trying to do to get my
mind from obsessing about the negative i
couldn't do it i could not do it i tried
i tried and tried but it was too much
but when i smoked it like cleared and i
could and i could
gain that perspective but more
importantly when i wasn't smoking i
could bring that perspective back with
me
yeah it's like internal therapy yes
that's exactly what it is i try to
explain it to like you know people that
don't get it it's hard it's like no
you're a [ __ ] loser no it's actually
really i'm working [ __ ] out yeah
the [ __ ] out oh so i did a ceremony on
an indian reservation native american
reservation in
uh san diego a couple of last month
and you know i've i've
i've
done uh mushroom ceremonies but never
like a huge dose all right and and this
guy said in our tradition we take a
pretty big dose he said we take 15 15
mushrooms
and so i was like
okay when in rome let's do it you know
and so but it was like a ceremony like
we were in the wampash in the circle and
there was a fire pit and like
it was profound it was like
deep you know like i connected to
something ancient yes it was
deep
you know
and
you know and i it just
connected me to like
there's so much more
going on in the world
like i mean like other dimensions that
we have the ability to access okay and i
think that's what these substances are
doing they're they're opening up our
sensitivity to these other dimensions
that's what we said about mushrooms and
dmt like it's just letting you see the
other frequencies yes the other level
because right now there's people right
here that don't see us either man yes
people talk about doing those ceremonies
at ayahuasca and dmt and [ __ ] like they
see the same thing yeah i've heard yes
like you'll see like animals and it's
like
wires and shoes our brains rewired and
all they did was go hey take that fuse
out for a second
and that allows because i think our
brain has so much potential and there's
p i think when we're babies with it's
open but it's shut down by our by our
conditioning these we're born with these
channels wide open but because our
parents aren't there and they don't
relate to us we just decide oh i guess
we don't need these and we turn them off
and the people that don't turn it off
are called crazy crazy people yeah
i know a lady my friend's mom actually
who i'm going to see tonight
she
she has a show her radio show she talks
about her stuff but
she
i mean i think it's completely real
because what she said to me when i
walked in the room and i didn't ask for
it
she legitimately sees ghosts walking
around yeah and she's like no no you
there's fun they're fine there's a
certain one certain dimension ones those
are the ones that you got to get out of
the [ __ ] room leave don't come back
but there's certain things she right
when i walked in and she described
somebody with me said something that i
wanted to say to that person that i
didn't get to say and i went i got
[ __ ] sick in my stomach yeah you know
you get that like hot feeling like what
the [ __ ] i'd even ask yes so i just ask
her
certain things sometimes and
she is pretty [ __ ] act i mean not
pretty accurate she's dead on with
things so
i know
that this stuff's real it's kind of hard
to talk about
because people think you're just a
[ __ ] lunatic and i understand people
do until we until we can normalize it
and the more like the more comfortable
and more intelligently people see other
people having the conversations because
everyone thinks this stuff all the time
anyway they're just too afraid but the
more they see people talking about it
they give themselves permission to share
their experiences and then it becomes
okay and then
we have more access to these other
dimensions because we start to
acknowledge that they exist so that we
all give ourselves permission to
interact with them
you know even like what you're
describing
a simple way to describe the other
dimension is a fee as a feeling
dimension right where someone can punch
you in the face and you can say ah that
hurt or someone could say something that
doesn't feel good and you can be like oh
that hurts but it's not your there's no
physical pain it's another
it's on a different level that you just
can't touch yeah exactly
exactly yeah that was a good way to put
that yeah and just the way you said that
there's going to be 30 people talking
about their experience of this
and that opens it up exactly yeah just
like i was telling you about the stories
before we started that opened up other
people they're like yeah all right well
you [ __ ] up when you were younger and
you're doing okay i'm like yeah because
i just want to excel that's everything
no matter what i'm doing even if i
wasn't doing this and i was working at a
company i'm trying to be employed the
month every [ __ ] month
you know it's just i think that's just a
working mentality
of just trying to be good you know i
love this you know so you know again we
were talking about elevating our message
and i had this download last night where
i was like heisman you know what is this
what is this really about
and and i and i'm an inspirational
person and the way i played sports and
how like even the story i told about
winning the heisman and breaking up i
ended up breaking up all those breaking
all three of those records oh we did we
went off to another table yeah yeah i
broke off i ended up breaking up
breaking all three of those records so
so i'm an inspirational person right
that i get the vision and it's about
achieving and in the attitude that my
mom taught me and then i've taken
through life she's a virgo moon the
attitude i've taken all through life is
that everything in life that shows up is
for is to help me develop that's the
purpose
that's the purpose of it showing up is
to help me develop
and so just that attitude has helped me
like
you know get all my resources and my
intelligence to be able to meet whatever
challenges were were coming up to me and
they've always led to more and more
growth
and i think that's a message that i've
lived by and i believe in it and this is
something that i feel really good about
putting out into the world
and so like the way i described it to
the team i said like we're like the real
life
spiritual nike
right it's like not just do it on the
field but it's really just show up in
life
right show up in life and that if if if
we
find a way to like surround ourselves
with like like-minded individuals that
share the same attitude and we approach
life is that that way ah there's no
stopping there's no there's no stopping
anybody that's how i feel every like we
said like as soon as we get some money
we're getting you started and you
started you started yes like i always
say it's a trickle down effect help your
cousin out and your cousin's gonna help
your other cousin then their kid comes
up and owns a store and you got i think
we can we can take entire blocks and
cities that way that's how i can take
the country that way yeah that's how i
think we we
like us that think like this on this
level if we come together we can take
the country i think we can
i think so man because i always say like
we just need people that have an
outreach to be
in any walk of life just be positive you
know what i'm saying but there's it's
not just positive you have to be
positive and you have to be intelligent
like
and you have to be like passionate right
it's all like these are all the planets
right each of the planets represent like
these qualities and we have all of the
planets oh it's not just the mars right
there's ten there's ten planets i said
thirty four ten ten planets twelve signs
12 what we call houses 34. oh [ __ ] this
is way crazy though you just scratched
the circle uh yeah uh yeah exactly
exactly that's why i don't like the i
don't like positive and uh negative yeah
people misconstrue that like when i
first we always talk about the secret
the book and the movie yeah and when i
first wrapped my mind around that it's
really easy to be like oh this is a
negative person it's a positive person
no you might take me as a [ __ ]
[ __ ] because i'm on a [ __ ] vicious
grind it's because i really believe in
this [ __ ] and i'm a super positive
person but i also don't put up with
[ __ ] anything
because of that because of that belief
so you might i might come off as a
[ __ ] negative person well i'm deep in
that grind that makes perfect sense
marty because
some people think i'm a [ __ ] dick
yeah it's not about positive and
negative i think that's the first thing
people misconstrue well for me i guess
the thing i'm trying to say is
anything i do is
for the better or try to do for the
better yeah that's 100
to me that's what being positive is yeah
you know what i mean i see my my i like
the way i live i say the first thing is
you got to show up that means who just
show up two keep it moving right it's
just gonna happen if you just keep it
moving we're gonna figure it out and the
third thing is enjoy the ride
right and if to me if you can get those
three things down like whatever whatever
shows up you got it yeah that's true
yeah i love that i love that too it's
like it kind of makes you like when i
get up in the morning i think i'm gonna
crush it today yeah that's the attitude
like whatever it is right i have what it
takes yeah it's gonna be the number one
thing i want for my kids is to have that
like to have something you're waking up
and getting after
just it might change throughout life
it's probably going to but just
something yeah no matter like when i was
delivering pizza i wake up like today
i'm gonna make 400 [ __ ] dollars in
tips i'm gonna sell hello weed out my
car this is the [ __ ] day no matter
what yes well if you can't do that
because sometimes people will try but
they can't get there it means you should
be doing something different because the
aim that should be the goal right you
should always be looking because
sometimes we do that and we feel it and
then it starts to fade away and we
pretend that it's still there it's
recognized relationships it happens too
recognize when it starts to fade and
like okay where else where else can i
generate this where else can i have this
that the target is that feeling not what
you're doing because what you're doing
that needs to change but that feeling
can always grow and always grow and it
always leads you into creating positive
things because like in life you only can
get out of something what you put in
true only and so just thinking about
like how about how am i investing my
energy how am i investing my time
because that's telling you not the exact
thing but it's telling you the quality
that you're going to get back that's
really what karma means it means you can
only get something
out of what you put in right if you plan
on apple seed it could only grow an
apple tree
oh you just broke that down better than
anybody on this [ __ ] show so far and
the things that i tried to say
i think you said it a little better than
i would try to say that's what i'm
mindful about even when i watch on tv or
whatever i don't like to watch movies
with people getting hurt because i'm
like i don't want to think about that
[ __ ] later i don't want that [ __ ] in my
life because whatever we think about we
energize
i'll have a nightmare yeah it's over
some weird [ __ ] yeah it's real and it's
not even anything to beat ourselves up
it's really just the laws of the way it
works it's whatever our mind is thinking
about that's where energy is directed
and so it's think about the things you
would like to have in your life right
and and be be aware of the things you'd
like to have in your life that are
actually possible for you to have or
things that are just you imagine you
would like to have that's an important
distinction and i think this is
important to say about
consuming cannabis is that it does
activate our imagination but our
imagination goes in two different main
directions it goes towards fantasy or it
goes towards creativity
and being able to recognize when it's
going towards fantasy and when it's
going towards creativity when you
recognize it going towards fantasy move
it over to creativity
and the difference is fantasy is
if this if this were different
everything would be better
that's fantasy okay oh yeah all i need
is this car it gets this money and
everything's done [ __ ] record deal
yeah oh
man i lived through that all i need is
netflix to give me some money i'll do it
and now i want to do we built their own
set [ __ ] warehouses
because fantasy it doesn't happen but if
you go to the creative if you go to the
creativity then you like you have the
inspiration and the vision
to but you got to do the work but you
got the inspiration and the vision to do
it that's a great example [ __ ] man you
really broke it down because that's how
i felt yeah i always just say uh when
are you going to make this show like one
day netflix is going to hit me up like
[ __ ] that i said this year's my
portfolio yeah for them like next year
i'm gonna come out like give me a
[ __ ] show
that's what it because it when i change
my mindset on that saying well one day
and i stopped saying it yes it was like
no i'm gonna all do it and they're gonna
come to
i
me
yes
exactly yeah love that that's sick
man inspirational episode for myself
this is [ __ ] great thank you this is
making me think different i really want
to know more about these 34
steps or 34 things you can see because
that is is more of like a
not a map quest but it's like hey man
it's that way and take a left and it's a
little bit down like at least i have a
direction yes that's 100 percent that is
beautiful yeah
love grace man thank you thank you so
let me get back on to something i wanted
to ask
i was watching i mean until i started
selling packs i watched football
religiously with my grandpa every sunday
because since i was a kid played
football collected cards that was my
thing right i was that kid i worked did
anything i could for my grandma cut guns
and go to copper comic and buy any cards
i could buy yeah right so that was me so
growing up obviously i'm watching
football every sunday i'm watching you
play football right so i'm playing
football at school but it's pre-selling
packs so i am
dedicated and trying to get straight a's
and [ __ ] b
i was like i wanted to go to texas tech
when i was a kid that's what my thing
was the guy gave some big football
player dude at the college when i was uh
watching the game gave me some hat he
had it had t t and i was like
tennessee
or texas like texas that's where i want
to play football i don't ever think it's
hot that was my goal as a kid to be a
[ __ ] lineman my mom goes when you're
an nfl player you buy me a house that's
all i want and we were walking on bear
creek going for a walk cause i was too
fat to play [ __ ] running back or
anything else because like i told you
earlier so when i'm watching it and i
see you playing and then you stopped
playing i mean you just stopped playing
and i didn't know about i mean
i'm not on google and [ __ ] i'm watching
espn but i don't really i'm watching
highlights and bruce berman and all this
[ __ ] do this [ __ ]
so
what made you stop i know why now but
what for the audience what made you
literally stop in the middle of a career
you were playing for what five years
right i played five years five years
yeah five years and then you stopped
because you were getting tested positive
for weed well that's not why i stopped i
stopped because there was
several messages from the universe that
i needed to do something different oh
see this is why i love this show because
only on the asp on espn and [ __ ] you
don't hear about this yeah this is dave
like well you know after many times and
violating and looks like he's going to
stop that's what the message i got as a
kid like wow that's it yeah
so this is please tell me what you're
saying
you saw messages like this is not what
i'm meant to do anymore exactly exactly
yeah and it's funny how the way it came
so
i was playing football and
you know i was in the locker room one
day and i just started i started when i
was smoking i started smoking more and i
when i was
at home smoking i started reflecting on
my life i reflect back and to think when
i was a kid you know i thought about
being famous because it would give me a
platform
to be able to like share truth right
that was like as a kid that was my dream
and then i was reflecting on what i was
doing in my life and i
realized i was way off track
that mainly what i was doing was
distracting people for a couple hours on
sunday that i didn't have enough of the
experiences
to feel good about my truths
until i realized i need to like go
travel and have experiences because if i
waste all my time just chasing this
football dream by the time it's done i'm
going to be too beat up and tired to be
able to go chase these passions
and so that was the thought and it kind
of scared me like
you know i can't do that it's the middle
of my career
and so
and so i i was like okay i'm just going
to play one more year and then i'll do
it and then i just started getting all
of these like signs like the coach quit
and then the new coach they hired was
like a first-time guy and dolphins
didn't have a quarterback and contract
negotiations were insulting it just was
like brick after brick and then i told
myself okay if i fail one more drug test
that's gonna be like i know for sure i'm
gonna go
and i knew it would work because if if i
felt a drug test it's confidential so no
one would know it would just be my
internal like
universe like deal
and so it was a week before training
camp and i ended up failing failing a
test that's a whole other story but i'll
save that one for later ended up failing
a test and i called up the nfl and i
said you know don't worry about me i'm
done i'm retiring i'm walking away and
it was done and and no one knew i felt a
drug test nothing right one of my best
friends at the time was a guy named dan
lebotard who worked for espn and has his
own podcast now that i do some stuff on
and he was a writer for espn the
magazine and a writer for the miami
herald at the time and as a as my best
friend i told him about the drug test
and i guess he felt like he was in a
difficult position because he was a
member of the media and if someone else
found out it would make him look bad and
so he the next morning he ended up
writing a story that i retired and it
was connected to the drug test but if he
had never said anything it would that
never would have been like it never
would have been part of the story
so
so that's why when people see the story
that's what
and it's there was a drug test but it
wasn't like they punished me
and then they kicked me out it was my
own internal thing of this is a sign
that it must really mean that it's time
for me to do something yeah that's the
sign yeah i get those i go time to leave
yeah you had already been fined a bunch
of times i've been fine i hadn't been
i'd failed i was in the drug program but
i hadn't been fined yet
and and it was one of those things where
the universe whispers to us okay and if
we if we hear the whisper we're rewarded
usually but a lot of times we don't and
then it speaks a little bit louder and
then if we hear the little bit louder
we're fine and then it has to like raise
its voice and that's when we start
getting like yeah you know a little
sting and then if we wait too long it
has to yell and then it's like a big
kick in the ass
and so for me i heard the whispers but i
ignored them and then it had to get
louder and had to get louder and i
finally and i finally listened
you know
so what i was just gonna say did you
feel like it was like i i just imagined
like most professional athletes smoke
weed did you feel like
was that the culture not so much well to
me it's not about
it's not about the weed to me it's more
about the effect of smoking so for me
when i started smoking my mind started
opening and realizing there's more
things to life than chasing money and
[ __ ]
like
right
like the preacher tried to tell me that
when i was a kid but he was chasing
[ __ ] too so it wasn't until like i had
my own experience of like there are more
important things than chasing like right
and that that woke me up and i realized
how much of my life was devoted to
chasing things that i wasn't even that
interested in
so i just got real with myself and i
said what would i really like to be
chasing truth
and there was none of that [ __ ] in the
nfl so i was like i gotta go look
somewhere else for it love it man
[ __ ] at least you recognize it and that
if you didn't then the universe wouldn't
[ __ ]
leg break next season man it's coming or
something crazy i'm telling you i knew
it i saw it i saw it and here's the
other thing about like that i was
talking about fantasy or creativity that
yes a lot of guys smoke but i think
they're smoking and moving more towards
fantasy
not creativity and the neces fantasy
sometimes is needed because sometimes we
need to be in our in a fantasy in order
to like survive because when when i was
in the nfl and they told me i couldn't
smoke anymore i was like fine no big
deal i stopped smoking and then i
realized if i wasn't smoking i would not
be doing this [ __ ]
until i realized sometimes we have to
smoke to create the fantasy to keep us
doing [ __ ] you know damn that's a
[ __ ] great way to put that [ __ ] get
[ __ ] up
oh we got him to stop smoking oh his
mind expanded [ __ ] he's gone yes that's
what happened yeah it's real that's why
the nfl needs to expand the game to
create a room for people that have
expanded minds right that's that's my
big push because to me it's it's stupid
that a person like me i'm a good person
right that there wasn't space for me in
the nfl according to their rules that's
not something wrong with me that's
something wrong with the nfl 100
especially when cte is such a mainstream
issue and mma and nfl like
the [ __ ] are we talking they should be
giving guys all reasonable means to be
able to take care of themselves 100 i
always say they're athletes bro that's
not an advantage
all right it's not an advantage all
right if anything it's an advantage to
themselves like you're like you were
using it yeah that is the advantage they
don't know about yes but i'm saying it's
not an advantage like you think michael
phelps took three bomb rips and
was gonna lose no he was gonna [ __ ]
win anyway he just smoked weed because
he wanted to smoke weed exactly you know
so you do your journey you go to india
you start realizing you see all these
fields and your brain expands you
realize all right my
i'm not even a person more of like this
energy what can i do with this yes well
just that there's something larger going
on and all of these crazy things that
are going on with me i feel connected to
something larger and that was more
intriguing and more interesting than the
football thing like i felt like i was
tapping into something even bigger than
football and i didn't know what it was
at the time but i trusted it and now
come full circle you know it started it
started to like make sense more
for sure yeah the football was you loved
it that was your
like i always say not everything's
supposed to be in your life forever yeah
you know things can come and go yeah
like football for me i have still have
dreams i quit over some dumb [ __ ] and i
loved it i mean i had dreams for still
do
that i'm getting my pads on i'm running
out and there's [ __ ] tunnel and i
wake up like [ __ ] man
i wasted it but then i'm like you know i
didn't i had [ __ ] fun when i did yes
you know but i quit over some stupid
[ __ ] that's the regret in my head is why
even more so i think the the part of the
conversation of things aren't supposed
to stay in our life is because things
come on our life to give us something
that you're saying to deal with or to
teach us something as soon as we deal
with it or get it it needs to move on
but whatever it gave us or taught us
that's ours forever and i think of like
i've been thinking about this a lot this
past week of
all like the mindset that gets nailed
into you as a football player is focus
on greatness focus on like being better
focus that's what i loved about football
it was one place i could go every day
and i was given permission to get better
and it wasn't threatening to other
people you know that he was encouraged
exactly everybody loved you more yes the
better you got exactly i get that
exactly that's cool and same thing with
wrestling it's like you are it's the one
it's one of the few sports that yo it's
[ __ ] on you
it's it's all you and then like he's
saying you got the good coach here and
then you got this over here that's the
same thing with wrestling it's
it's only you everyone's staring at you
it's not it's not a team sport at this
point it's a whole wrestling gave me
[ __ ] anxiety when i was a little kid
i hated it but i loved wrestling i hated
going i'm like i don't like all these
people looking at me and then i'd forget
that they were [ __ ] there and start
wrestling but with football it's a
different
i think it's different well for you i'm
over here talking about it for you it's
different because you are on yours that
was one of my questions you're a college
kid you win the heisman you're on espn
you're transitioning to all these things
and now you're like
nfl contract i'm on espn i'm the talk of
the [ __ ] town
wow this is one of these moments right
one of these moments you look back like
all right well i'm here so you're in
there and then you realize it's that was
great that was fun that was a chapter i
don't care for right now you leave and
then what makes you come back
a couple of things so one was that when
i left the dolphin sued me for like nine
million dollars so that was one
motivation
it wasn't the main motivation the main
motivation was when i started going
around the world and traveling i
realized i have work to do
right and because of the way i left the
nfl in order for me to do my work i have
to go back and kind of right the ship in
other people's eyes
to get on like the good foot and then i
could i'll be able to keep keep up with
my path so i came back to the nfl and
that's exactly what i did you know i had
another thousand yard season everyone
you know liked me again and then i was
able to walk away on my own terms
gotcha and it opened the door so that
now i could be doing it doing what i'm
doing now
so you basically
i see exactly what you're saying you had
to go back to
like you said like everybody liked me
again i'm the football guy again it's
just because this but it is it's also
part of the story right people love a
redemption story right they feel even
more connected because we've been
through things together you know in a
relationship right when you've gone
through something with someone it like
makes you even like tighter exactly and
i feel like the fans like real fans when
i left they were pissed off then i came
back and helped the team win and they
got to like feel better again like again
we've been through stuff and and i feel
that was yeah and it's a human rights
issue at the core of it yeah it really
is because they're like discriminating
against you based on some nonsense yeah
and it's really it's like affected the
course of your life yeah but the the
thing that i that i will say the
difference in in team sports and
specifically
football for they say football is the
ultimate team sport
is
is you have that like sense of it's just
me but that sense is expanded to this
feeling right this sense is expanded to
include 10 other guys
and so like even when they the way they
talk about an offensive scheme right
it's it's 11 guys that are on the same
page and there's nothing like it when
there's that perfect play where everyone
does their job oh that's my that's what
i preach god i love when people do their
jobs yes
i love it i came in everything was
organized what oh yeah
that's my i don't know it maybe goes
back to my perfection brain thing but
like yo i do my job that's perfect
repeat it like i was thinking traffic
like if everybody's just nice to each
other bro there is no traffic yeah
that's what i think in lax that's the
planet pluto actually
that's the planet pluto what is what is
that it's a planet of uh cooperation or
coercion
oh all right right so so i used to have
meanings this is [ __ ] crazy
i use the example of the of the nfl even
the whole thing about the drug policy is
the idea
is
cooperation or coercion and there's
usually both in co-op the ultimate of
cooperation is what i was talking about
with on a football team where you have
11 especially in the nfl you have 11 of
the best athletes in the world that have
honed their talents and they're all
contributing to one scheme right to
being a part of a larger whole
right but the specific thing is their
specific talents are being utilized to
make the whole thing work right so this
is so the example from a spiritual
perspective is that we're all here
right to contribute something to the
whole yeah and and when we find what
that thing is it like gives us this
passion right where that's where i get
like show up keep it moving and enjoy
the ride because if you find the right
thing that's all you have to do when
everything is taken care of right so
that's why as an nfl football player
like i found my niche as the running
back i had a certain kind of running
back and all i had to do was show up
keep it moving and have fun and
and that was me playing my part and if
everyone else was doing that right we
kicked everyone's ass right so but but
and practice okay now the coercion part
okay we've all agreed that we're
committing to greatness we've all agreed
to cooperate in this mission to beat
this team okay so because we've all
agreed we've given the people in charge
permission to coerce us to being to
doing our job so an nfl coach will say
literally okay put on the film okay
it'll show people [ __ ] up and he'll
say
do your job or we will get your ass out
of here that's exactly what they say do
your job or we'll find someone who will
it seems so cutthroat right that's
coercion but it but it's positive
coercion if you want to win and it's a
coercion that people have to buy into
and so like
but so that's why it's important to
choose the right group so that when
there's coercion you feel like this is
good for me and and for the nfl to say
you're not allowed to consume cannabis
that's coercion
based on being part of a group and for
me i had to realize
this is not my group
okay
this is not my group yeah right because
there there is excellence and i love
that part but there's not enough
expansiveness to for me to really be me
and so i had to leave that group and and
find another group that was me that
where there's that same level of
excellence but there's more of an
expansiveness
and that's what i and i've and i've been
looking for it but i finally realized
it's what i have to create
and so that's what i'm creating in the
businesses that i'm starting is that and
and even the communities that i'm trying
to start is the community that's built
off of these principles
damn wow you broke that down so well the
thought policy is still the same no
they've changed um like now they they
don't suspend players anymore for
cannabis they'll find them still but and
they shorten the testing window so fine
4 17 of their salary
what
or seven
it's probably four eighteenths now it
was four seventeens because it's four
game checks and they're 17 weeks of the
season oh
they take four games
that hurts
that would make [ __ ] stop
smoking
[Laughter]
okay i didn't know it was that bad
whoa
man i remember they find tara owens for
doing the [ __ ]
pen in the thing but that was like 50k i
think it was yeah he definitely doesn't
make
yeah i mean
i mean hopefully they've lowered the
fines and i guess to me i didn't even
like
i was so in it i didn't even think of it
that way but yeah that's a that's a lot
of money that's a lot of money yeah but
if you love something you don't even
look at it exactly oh man what a dilemma
to be in man
so you came back to me though again it
wasn't about the weed it's it's related
because it's about what it represents
and to me anyone that's not for my
greater good is not for me and to me and
it might sound crazy
but for me
cannabis was better for me than the nfl
at least in my in my mind in the math i
did and it seems to be like it worked
out to be true
well you know what you want and you're
an in-touch person and especially with
yourself you know what you need and you
say you you know the biggest thing that
people don't recognize are the whispers
that you talked about yes yeah you'll
see it though people call it red flags
yeah yeah but the whispers are
if you're in touch with yourself like we
know like nope we'd get off the phone
with the me and him be able to call
somebody get off call each other god no
i don't feel this guy i could tell
something in his voice tells me to stay
away it whispers and then we find out we
were [ __ ] whispering every time
whispers yeah that's true it's true man
thank you for that that was a like i
said after we're done i really want to
know more about this or whatever
whatever i can do and you say you do
this for a living now yeah so
what does that mean someone comes to you
and goes hey i need help in my life
something's wrong or i need i would like
to learn more you sit them down and it's
like a session with a person exactly
exactly what it is a consultant yeah
yeah a life consultant essentially an
energy consultant but really though but
i feel like uh i'm not trying to be
someone's like
coach it's more i'm showing them how to
do it themselves 100 you're for the
tools exactly i'm giving them i'm
teaching them how to understand
themselves and how to understand other
people and it's like this cool process
because i always bring it back to
people's brilliance their awareness
because so many of us have been beat up
because here's what i've realized right
the best the most powerful parts of
ourselves okay is what is the [ __ ] that
our parents had to deal with and if
parents are smart they want to disable
the most powerful parts of their kids to
make the kids easier to deal with and so
for most of us the things that are like
the best parts of ourselves we've been
twisted to think are bad
and so part most of the work i do with
people is to like try to like
you know disavow them of those beliefs
and show them in the chart how the chart
shows these are your greatest strengths
and they know it inside but no one's
ever told them and so it's just giving
them that information right you can see
them like brighten up and they start to
lean into it a little bit because they
knew like yo somebody validated what
i've been thinking my whole exact life
exactly and when you see it comes from
something in the universal and the stars
it just is more power it's more it's
something bigger yes it's like yo i'm
just one thing in this whole [ __ ]
circuit that's a trip like josh the
owner of raw he's like i'm a i'm a link
in a chain and from 300 years ago they
were a link i'm trying to be the best
link i could possibly be in this life so
the next person has an easier goal and
crushes it harder yes like the best way
i loved that
oh man i love this this is great so tell
me more please uh we talked about a
little before you got here
probably the best name you probably
could have picked for a company yeah i
mean thank you for picking the [ __ ]
daddy
what a good day man thank you i'm sorry
so heisman is your brand and it's a
legal company california or other states
it's california we're in oregon and
we're expanding to at least three other
states this year nice man congrats on
that so can you tell us about it what
when did you start this
and i you just said we're like the
spiritual nike yeah i'll talk to my team
what's our message is the first time
i've ever heard a cannabis company go
what's our message yeah you know it's
more about like who are we paying this
month uh like what are we gonna do what
billboard am i gonna get which is great
because that's advertising yeah but that
seems like you're like you said it's not
about the candle it's not about the
smokiness that's why i keep telling you
that's why i keep telling guys we're not
selling weed like i have to say that
like every day because they get so
caught up in the outside stuff and i say
we have to sell something like bigger so
a vision like we got to sell something
that inspires people i love that and i
said but if it's only on the outside and
it's just the messaging then it's like a
pretty girl who's rotten on the inside i
said we have to live this we have to
embody it so it comes through our pores
and anyone that interacts with our brand
they feel it they feel it and it's you
know what the brand is and is really
everything we've been talking about and
when did it start it started when i was
in college and i and i smoked and i had
back-to-back 300-yard games i didn't
know it was starting there but that's
when it that's when the seed was planted
okay is that there's something about
this plant and we've been lied to like
drastically and actually this plant
could be the key to us going to the next
level right and i had that as a seed
thought but it took me years of
experience and exploration and education
to get to the point where i feel like
i 100 know with confidence that this is
real
and and with that i have a platform and
i've been able to to put a team together
and this is what we're this is the
message we're getting out into the world
officially the company came together
last fall
and we we launched in in dispensaries
and online in november
and really the focus right now is is
again building the message and building
building this community i love it man
like i said
i work like i told you my other stuff is
what i do i do
i've been doing weed
content for almost maybe a decade this
year so i've seen companies come and go
i've seen companies sprout and become
huge and i've never seen anybody take
that that route yeah of
it's bigger than weed yeah like you said
earlier no it's not just me i'm part of
something bigger so you're implementing
that and
well football was a chapter and now
you're on how can i spread this message
it's like yeah can i get your attention
do i have your attention let me tell you
something more yeah come here come here
sit down take a seat smoke this listen
yes exactly that's 100
with what i'm doing yeah 100 i like this
this is cool this is cool so where
where can everybody find your dispensers
across california and oregon you said
across california and we're in oregon
yeah and uh all the dispensaries are
listed on our website heisman.com
you got that wow you got that website
yeah surprise actually it wasn't gone
yeah
so i got a eight-year-old boy to running
back yeah and he's
i'm gonna say he's a little christian
mccaffrey [ __ ] juking fools
hard yeah and you can see it he's doing
weights in the morning
[ __ ] doing his own workout regimens
sorry he's i love cam he's so hard yeah
he is but what do you foresee like kids
growing up playing football would you
even recommend that to a kid now with
like studies coming out about brain
damage and just like how violent it is
like if a kid loves football coming up
would you even
be like yeah that's probably that's a
good path to go down i wouldn't push a
kid towards it but if he had that
passion hell yeah i would support it you
know but i would be real so like my my
son sounds just like you like football
loves to collect cars he loves
loves football he loves football but
he's like a sensitive like kid you know
so i try i try to explain to him i say
football is great you're going to learn
a lot and it's a great game but as you
go up higher and higher like
the kids aren't as nice you know
and because there's a certain kind of
like football player at different levels
and i'm trying to explain to him that
like you know so and i just put that
thought in there so he'll stick with it
as long as he can but he won't force
himself to stick with it longer than he
should because he's trying to prove
something yeah because i think that's
what happens
that's what happened with me i realized
that when i was a kid playing football
was a way i could prove that i was like
tough because people used people used to
pick on me because they said i i talked
like a [ __ ] and because i was smart and
so i felt i found that through playing
football they would respect me as a
person gotcha um and then but i just
took it like way too far to where i got
the respect and i was like okay i got
the respect now like now what's next
yeah now it's next yeah that's a good
that's a good way to shut a bully
yeah
turn your tv on yeah it worked
oh you got my jersey yeah
that's like one of those shoes for the
moon hit the stars oh yeah man that's
the beginning of space jam like oh a
ten-year-old dunked right now oh my god
so so you know i'm not a person that
does regrets but when i look back and i
say if i was rewriting the story what
would i change and i'd say when i when i
won the heisman trophy i would have
taken a year off and i would have
traveled around the world
no i would have just i would have
because the nfl would have been there
but i would have had that anyway i would
have had that experience and that that
depth and that appreciation of like what
is this for because i did it five years
later i just did it five years later and
i came back and the biggest difference
was when i got to the nfl i was kind of
like
you know what do i have to do to fit in
and when i came back i was like how can
the nfl help me accomplish my goals and
that's when it became so much more
interesting and dynamic for me
love that yeah it's a lot of low power
that's not it it truly is a lot of
confidence to stop something that you're
so ingrained of like no this is your
whole personality you are the running
back you're gonna run them over you're
gonna quit the whole world had to be
like what the [ __ ] yeah like dave
chappelle leaving comedy center oh dude
that was me as a little kid like what do
you mean my grandpa oh he's done
because i'm a [ __ ] car collector
and which brings me on to my next house
i'm a very very big car collector yeah i
would watch the nfl i'm like yo i got
that guy's card i got the rookie i'm
gonna put i was that kid with a little
uh
you know the screw gun with the plastic
cards so i was at copper comic i got a
pack of cards and i got the rookies
rookie cards i'm like yo what the [ __ ] i
just saw this [ __ ] played i
didn't say [ __ ] i was a kid only
i saw the guy play the other day and i
sealed it up so i sealed this card in
the sixth grade
no way
never opened let me see this
that's a real rookie card oh that's the
real one oh wow
i got that at copper comic i was so
hyped about a five pack of thing and
it's like get a rookie and had it on the
front like what the [ __ ] i can get a
rookie card and a pack of cards for five
dollars and i just remember like seeing
the card and i just sealed it wow
what a trip
nice
badass
oh that's so cool it's dude i have a
extensive collection i did that to the
new guy for the patriots too i found my
tom brady rookie the other day i didn't
know i had i sealed it cause i'm like
nah that guy's gonna be [ __ ] great
drew bledsoe's gone he's the next wave
and i found it drunk as [ __ ] with my
friends the other day i'm like you don't
know i got cards and i found a rook you
go dumb pretty rookie card
all right
yes i found that one i got a bart star
before there was tops i mean i got an
extensive collection the joe namath you
know at the end of the you have now
watched the nfl it's joe namath looking
up i have that card original i got i'm
i'm deep as a kid i had the [ __ ]
becket book
i got all my no i was that look did you
check out the the tom brady rookie in
the background hey bands
that's your chat twenty eight thousand
dollars and i bought that [ __ ] for like
forty dollars i remember i got the mic
all-star remember i'm like michael
allstat's rookie i got i got everybody
man i got everybody so um
i was going to ask if i opened this up
would you sign this thing of course i
would
i'm sealing it right back up
oh yes
finally yes as soon as our booking agent
goes it goes says ricky william yeah
i'm going through my cards
they're like i know it's in the brown
box i keep all the good ones in the
brown box with the cases
yes thank you
making me uh pretty [ __ ] excited
right now thank you so much for that um
so that that's really um everything i
wanted to ask marty if you had anything
else or if you had any of the fan
questions
i got a question how intense is the
trash talking in the nfl to the point
that the refs like stop it or don't stop
it is it horrific that's it has to get
bad for the refs to stop it
like the refs will stop it when they see
that someone is actually going after
someone where it gets a little they let
like the little banter and the fun stuff
go back and forth but when it turns like
real then they usually step in yeah yeah
yeah because they mic'd up they only mic
up to people like hey you're on mic man
yeah make us look good okay don't be
saying something exactly and usually is
you know there's at most two guys maybe
three on each on a team that talks [ __ ]
oh no [ __ ] yeah i would have thought it
would have been so i thought the whole
time
there's like one or two guys on each
team at that level i'm imagining i
played [ __ ] d2 basketball people
everybody's ego was out of control yeah
i couldn't imagine up at that highest
level of the nfl where the egos are at
they they are to a certain extent but
when when every day after work you have
to go back and watch and look at all
your mistakes you know
it humbles you it humbles you a little
bit i i feel like are you talking about
film or like espn okay film so every day
after prac after practice practice um we
go and watch film a practice
every day every day it is your job
that's the job you're accountable for
everything you do exactly the holy
spirit i can't believe i just opened
that right now
wow
the air of 2001 just popped up right now
got some weed smoke oh perfect i mean my
life coming full full circle weed smoke
on it now
thank you so much
when you open this again in 10 years
we're going to be like it smells like
[ __ ] ocean
oh we'll let that new thank you so much
for doing that dude of course i
appreciate that a lot
um
so i have a question actually
as a football fan
i wanted to ask
who's the i know nobody's afraid of [ __ ]
who's the people you go oh damn that
we're playing that fool all right i'm
gonna try to crack his ass today or
let's hope i don't get cracked by this
full today yeah so um
ray lewis i already knew it yeah i got
that's number one on the list
um
john lynch was one john lynch
sean lynch is such a badass man um
rodney harrison was like is a dirty
player and he plays hard but i was never
afraid of him
uh
lawyer malloy
he brings it so i wasn't afraid but i
had to like always be on the lookout
make sure you i know where you're at on
the field exactly you know those guys
were they would hold me up and i could
hear them coming and i learned it like
that
yes i learned to get down to the last
moment because i could hear them coming
i never really thought about that [ __ ]
like because i never got the ball as a
fat kid i care this full
this pancake especially me because you
know i'll take a hit and i'll try to
keep going but i can hear those guys
coming and i'll keep going i'm like okay
i'm done i'm not taking this hood
that's something i never thought of like
the anxiety of
this was holding me oh they're like in
here there's stumps like jurassic park
right now
oh man it must be a trip because
i always think i always thought about it
as a kid you know especially you you're
like nfl maybe one day yeah i guess but
i always thought about like
they're monsters out there
but if you're skilled enough it doesn't
matter how big anybody is or what they
bench well here's the thing about
football like to a certain extent but
it's really your teammates it's there's
monsters out there but we got monsters
too
that's the ideal feeling it's the bad
feeling is there's monsters out there
and you look around and you're like oh
i'm the monster
that's not fun that is not fun oh man
yes yeah i i always have put my i'm a
[ __ ] football fan so i had to ask man
yeah i had to ask so um your son how old
your son he's uh 11.
oh so he's not even at the age of like
committing yet if you're saying he loves
football but he's he's not really at
that level he's committed though he's
committed oh he is in he's in oh i
thought you meant like he wasn't really
fully into it he was he was trying to
like say he wanted to play and i was i
wasn't trying to talk him out of it i
was just trying to give him like the
perspective like the real perspective
you know and if and if he knows the
truth and he still wants to go i'm 100
going to support you but i'm not going
to lie to you and have you be surprised
that's not cool yeah no i understand
that that's that's good that's what this
guy does for cam too um like i said his
son is well he's only eight but
he's on that path like you were saying
like well you're not playing for college
that's not what marty did he just went
not at all he just records him and go
how the [ __ ] is this little boy so fast
that's full it's like playing madden or
uh gameday 99. with dorsey levin's you
just l2 r2 and he just juice we just
moved
he moved and i came out he's got the
[ __ ] laundry on the bench press
like a prisoner on the squat rack
they're in it he's got those kids you
can't stop him
there's nothing you can do they know
what the path is exactly and i wish i
had i mean i love what i'm doing but as
a child like i wish i had a direct oh
you said i wish i had somebody i
respected enough to go hmm
that [ __ ] was pretty cool all
right cool that's what i would like to
do too yes or at least i would like to
strive to be
like i never seen the [ __ ] hold
the door open for a girl before yeah you
know so i do it every [ __ ] time to
make sure it's a point now my little
brother will not not do it and i love
that [ __ ] yeah it's like implementing
things of like no be positive that's my
thing like you're saying
you're saying it's not about being
positive or negative but that's my my
mindset of
do good [ __ ] i
know when no one's looking that's the
biggest thing when no one's looking
still do that pick up that trash anyway
[ __ ]
because it's an energy even if no one's
looking the energy is there yeah and it
makes me feel so much better man because
sometimes we're doing [ __ ] like yeah man
it's for me yeah it's for me to know
that i did that [ __ ] by myself i think
that's where the buck comes from that's
your intention like uh credit karma
score like your car that's your car oh i
like that like you know your energy
points your intentions
exactly exactly it's like you're saying
if
a lot of people might look at the
astrology thing go energies uh yeah okay
but you can get it right now oh i felt
that fool's vibes yeah you can measure a
brainwave a brainwave is a thing you can
physically you can physically measure
that and you can read that out on a
diagram so i feel like man i feel you
just opened up my brain a little bit to
some other [ __ ] i really appreciate i'm
a gemini that's what gemini's do we open
we open people's minds i love that man i
remember the first time a friend told me
about yeah you know eating this and that
and that and that's when i stopped
eating
almost everything like no that's
poisonous for me process is what and
that's when i found out about things and
i ran with it yeah now my brain's more
of like no just implement like yo man
try this yeah and now my friends are
more on the
track i'm trying all right so it's it's
trying without badgering and budge and
like
shoving [ __ ] down someone's throat
because you didn't go no you need to be
on it astrology you're not on it you
need to you're not for your full
potential you didn't do that [ __ ] to me
it would have made me go
[ __ ] you williams
internally yeah that's it yeah but now i
am [ __ ] interested because you
explained like you said i didn't have a
language yeah that was the language you
broke it down enough to me to where i'm
like wow i'm interested this peaked my
[ __ ] like you said what's your mars that
piqued my interest yeah
exactly got me thank you for doing that
yeah of course thanks for having me two
weeks later
this would be chris is all over my table
today
mars
what kind of what kind of music are you
into
um you know like i get in phases and the
only thing i really listen to right now
is like damian marley oh okay so i'm
like like reggae that has a message
because again whatever
we're consuming and when i hear that
music every time it uplifts me so i just
like get into like
a groove with it that's another thing if
it's if it's energy and stuff's not real
the music would make you feel things
exactly and that's why
people preach against certain music like
no it's it's not good for kids to listen
to it i used to think you know it's a
song
no it's [ __ ] true because i've seen a
lot of my friends that did it yeah start
[ __ ] emulating things they think or
feel and now where the [ __ ] are those
guys now they're the guys that we saw
like outside the liquor store exactly
good it's funny like you know when i was
13 i i was introduced to bob marley and
and i think this is kind of part of how
i got here and i wasn't like i wasn't
there like saying no to drugs as a kid
but i was a huge bob marley fan and so i
i was comfortable separating the two
because his music had uplifted me as a
kid i'll come home from school sit down
play video games and just listen to bob
all night long and just listening to
that music and like talking about free
in the mind and
you know taking care of people it wasn't
like selfish it wasn't about him it was
always this larger message and i think
that music listening to it over and over
and over again it got in there you know
it got in there and it nourished me and
i think it
it's it's why i'm doing what i'm doing
now
well that's that's the
music is the number one thing i think
that could spread any message and i
think it because music is universal man
you know like you said it's the lane
it's the language it's a different
language so
it's all it's
all connecting back to each other and i
love that man thank you so much for that
yeah i really appreciate that marty
do you have anything else you want to
talk about because i i i went through
everything about this i didn't realize
that we were going to like touch on like
i didn't i ever wanted to say on the
show
we talk about this a lot it doesn't come
out so it doesn't come out like
[ __ ] stop messing up that's the
[ __ ] i do stop doing that stupid [ __ ]
yeah it's it's better when you cut well
you also have experience with this and
you know yourself so like it's saying
you have faith in yourself so it's more
you already know i hopefully
one day and go hey man
sit down with me says i got you because
i do that now like like i tell you like
everywhere i go man i'm consulting no
matter what i do i'm consulting like
what can i help you with that and it's
just
him talking to his trainer that's very
good
you've got to build a website i mean you
got to get the website my trainer that's
not dude you got to you can get it you
can crush it you do it but just do this
two things yeah yeah so that virgo
that's the sun that's virgo really
that's very good what the [ __ ] that's
all right converge wants to like virgo
wants to become really good at something
so that it can be more helpful yes
that's the other part of the sentence so
like the getting good the process of
working towards perfection it's not
about for the self it's perfection so
that i have something that i can offer
that i feel really good about often
percent i want to get rich i can buy
everybody houses they cannot worry
that's the goal mm-hmm all right so oh
man i got a letter do you know josh
kesselman you guys are very much the
owner of raw i'm i think i met him a
couple of times yeah somewhere in mexico
yeah traveled the world yeah yeah one
job when you sit down with josh it's he
always i always
tell him i owe him a lot of [ __ ] because
there was time like the mars thing where
i was [ __ ] aggressive and [ __ ] and
pissed off and he told me and we talked
about on the show he told me a few
things i still use it today
he's like be appreciative of what you
have and what your brain can do for
yourself and then start your day yeah
wow it's like a tranquil feeling i'm not
even all [ __ ] mad anymore it's like
it's crazy that
your your brain is all you need to like
it's self-sufficient you can really be
self-sufficient
and do like you like you're like you're
saying like oh i'm an nfl yeah i did i
did my thing
now i got to do this for myself when i
come back now i can spread this even
better and the money from that is making
sure i'm okay over here while i travel
the world and do these things yes i love
it yeah good [ __ ] man it power it
powered uh it powers some positivity
man to that oh yeah let's go love this
[ __ ] episode yes thank you yeah dude
i have a question how long have you been
doing this episode 150. i knew it was it
could never tell it could have been
[ __ ] four hours yeah i have no idea i
was thinking maybe at least around two
hours uh-huh thank you so much for being
of course i really appreciate you being
you
i was hyped oh of course i'm excited
obviously [ __ ] i'm excited but i
really more excited to
learn more of what you're talking about
yeah it's just cool stuff yeah because
if this is
allowing you to expand and do this
that's only going to be better for us
which is better for everybody else yeah
because
we're trying to always lead by example
you know you got an iphone yet yeah so i
have an app uh your own app i have my
own app yeah it's called it's called uh
leela lila astrology
l-i-l-a astrology yeah and so we
we've been working on it for a while but
we're really starting to pick up
momentum and so it's it's early and it's
new but it's it's in the app store and
it's continuing to to grow nice yep
that's that one yeah relate deeper yeah
oh
all right i'm downloading right now
wow man so i can i can learn a lot more
about this yeah but you will have to
find your birth time
i'm always getting my birth certificate
it was like six in the morning i don't
know exactly what time yeah
but you do have a birth certificate yeah
yeah yeah just get it from just get it
off there yeah and then put the time in
and start to read and you'll kind of get
you'll get just by reading what we
created you'll get a better
understanding of what's going on
i'm actually excited yeah i know
i'm actually excited for that yeah all
right use your virgo too yeah yeah yeah
all right but you'll get to see you'll
get to see all 34 symbols in action when
you get everything you're talking about
in the app yeah oh man all right i'm
about to i have to my friend's bachelor
party's first basketball i've ever been
to but i have to go there tonight so wow
there's gonna be a lot of time to just
when we're all sitting and chilling that
i'm gonna be the only dude like
everybody's getting [ __ ] up like
[ __ ] astrology
my sign nah [ __ ] get off me
oh [ __ ]
see and that's the point of this [ __ ]
all right we can talk about some real
[ __ ] and bring it back to [ __ ]
i'm just learning about rocks
oh man thank you so much thank you so
much ricky williams for being here this
great episode man i'm really i
appreciate this and
now that you're here anytime you want to
do anything let us know i sure would
excited this is this is what we do we
it's podcasting but we're also
in the weed space i mean that's what i
do we do
full-on [ __ ] apple
crate i'll show you a few things like we
take like we said we try to perfect
things i started doing videos up close
and now we're
getting rigs and
cinematics cinematic cannabis
content oh i love our videos man i want
to show you i'll show you some things
man so that's what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to make it
yo it's totally normal you can smoke
weed and be [ __ ] stuff i have six
businesses man i'm [ __ ] tired but i'm
gonna get it done yes you know i just
got an assistant and she's helping the
[ __ ] out of me so i'm trying to expand
and this is i mean you know we know our
fans i'm just so happy that
they got introduced to you this way i'm
i'm i love football i love all that but
everything else is one of my i did not
know i was gonna be so [ __ ] excited
about this like that's something that's
right up my alley that i want to better
my my brain i can tell like yeah i'm
[ __ ] stoked yeah
all right all right cool i have to drive
so now i'm all awake and [ __ ] thank you
so much for being here uh where can
everybody find you online so uh my
personal uh i'm on twitter uh at rick
the laureate i'm on instagram williams
and people who want to interested in
astrology i want to learn more at
rickywilliams.life
rickywilliams.life yeah and then the app
is l-i-l-a
overlay it's over the script
thank you so much for being here man
appreciate you thank you thank you thank
you uh marty thank you i appreciate it
all right thank you so much for being
here i appreciate it guys from the dopes
usual podcast from marty
ricky and i have a dope ass day
yeah
man
okay so
so
if somebody come like i can go to you
and we can be like sid let's sit down
let's do one of these sessions
[Music]